Rubina Aniki bulla got engaged in june
teachers they come to chill certain
garden for dates three times a week it
is nice for a picnic and a pleasant
place for men and women to enjoy time
together without any harassment
chul-soo tone is cobbles largest
historic public garden and just reopened
to the public this summer it had laid in
ruins for 26 years after it was heavily
damaged in the Civil War and you can
still see sides of that conflict on the
walls of the buildings before the Civil
War
it was peaceful but during the Civil War
they destroyed it it was in pieces still
during the war I came here I would walk
and jog around the garden for exercise I
never stopped in the 90s this was the
front line abdul qadir has lived
opposite the garden all his life now he
brings his grandchildren entrance used
to be free because all the walls were
destroyed now it's 40 cents which keeps
the park running I was thinking wow the
economy rim at the end of the day when I
go home and I think about the people I
remember the smiles on their faces and
it really makes me proud and it's not
just smiles green urban spaces bring
economic and community benefits to in
Kabul it's rare to find a safe space
where children can run and adults can
connect scientists are also finding
increasing evidence that big green
spaces boosts mental health
chul-soo tune is not the first historic
garden to get a new life in Kabul it is
following the success of Babel Gardens 3
opened in 2008 after it too was heavily
damaged in the civil war it now gets
more than 1 million visitors a year the
park was built by the first emperor of
the mughal dynasty barber after he
conquered the city in the early 1500s
baba baba was a personality a poet a
scholar a pioneer as well as a leader he
was always thinking about the people of
Kabul and that this city is paradise
baba will always say these gardens are a
gift from heaven Babu is buried here he
demanded at home with no roof so he
could see the sky and here people enjoy
his garden this is what Babu can hear
not explosions or sirens but Afghans
embracing a rare urban oasis and a
little joy Charlotte Ballas aljazeera
Kabul